you're a very affable youthful presence
in your work you really are thank you
but I'm curious are you starting to
think about you know I'll speak for
myself I'm no spring chicken and know
I'm about to turn 30 and and I'm just
wondering do you ever think about I
think about sometimes looking down the
road do I have a plan for aging in this
business where people feel like you're
not allowed to age you know I know it's
I mean yeah I hear those footsteps also
I mean there's you know we're on the
back nine let's face it you know that's
a nice way to put it at least you're
playing at least when the way you you
you put it we're playing a nice game out
yeah yeah it's just and not well the
tomb is getting closer you know but it
is you know I find myself kind of doing
you know taking more walks and things
that you know as a kid I didn't even get
like you know going for a walk yeah do
what like where we're right there we go
trees like you know I'd walk up to
7-eleven and play asteroids but just to
walk and now it's like I do walks and
hmm you know you can also do little
things that kind of trick you into still
now they have those ebikes and I'm not
getting on those ebikes you know that
where you just bomb around and you kind
of feel like you're like a kid on a
ten-speed yeah and so that's nice but I
mean I do get people you know sometimes
saying you know I'll show up at work and
they're like oh you had a late night
last night and it was like they didn't
have a late night way into it because
it's like you know they're like you did
not get a good sleep and it's like no I
had like 10 hours no I say yeah I did
have a late night I don't want to say no
this is how I look now I just look yeah
tired around the know when people say
that you have to say you can't say this
is me fully rested oh the best I'm going
to live today exactly but I mean there
is that you know I remember reading this
when this LA Times columnist was
retiring and he said he had just had
like a stroke and was in a wheelchair
you know but could still write and was
saying that there are three stages to
life you
middle-aged and you're looking good
because that's what people always tell
him now he's in the wheelchair you're
looking good no looking good I think we
have to be happy to be in middle age I
guess at least we're not in the you're
looking good yeah yeah I have to say no
one looks at me and says you're looking
good no one thankful no one says that
yeah I don't want you to have that
stroke that's if this guy is TV why did
you say it like why did you say this yes
exactly
what would make you think I would stroke
I know where did you get that idea
sorry about that all right well just let
me know when it's coming so I can get
ready yeah shoot three bottles of
aspirin
you